proviseur le rôle principal signé raphaë
HCH dorane et Patrice leddin un film qui
vous l'avez compris nous fait découvrir
le quotidien des chef d'établissement
que de tâches à accomplir que de
problèmes à régler tous les jours de
tous les côtés les conditions sont-elles
vraiment réunies pour que il et elle
puissent remplir leur mission dans de
bonnes conditions on va en parler sur ce
plateau avec nos invités Stéphane
piernoir bienvenue à vous vous êtes
sénateur LR de menéire membre de la
commission de la culture de l'éducation
et de la communication vous êtes
président de l'office parlementaire
d'évaluation des choix scientifiques et
technologiques je précise enfin que vous
êtes vous-même enseignant de profession
pierre mathieio bienvenue à vous vous
êtes politologue directeur de Sciences
polille donc directeur d'établissement
vous aussi vous êtes l'un des maîtres
d'œeuvre des réformes de Jean-Michel
Blanquer vous avez beaucoup travaillé
sur l'éducation prioritaire je rappelle
aussi que l'ancien ministre de
l'éducation nationale a notamment œuvré
au renforcement du rôle des chefs
d'établissement Éric charbonnier
bienvenue vous êtes analyste éducation à
l'OCDE l'organisation de coopération et
de développement économique c'est l'OCDE
qui a créé il y a plus de 25 ans
maintenant le fameux classement PISA
programme international pour le suivi
des acquis des élèves Véronique Roset
bienvenue à vous vous êtes proviseur du
lycée international des pontonniers à
Strasbourg et vous êtes secrétaire
national chargé des carrières au sein du
principal syndicat des chefs
d'établissement le SNPD e merci beaucoup
à tous les quatre d'être ici et d'avoir
accepté notre invitation d'abord un mot
du documentaire si vous le voulez bien
le point commun de ces trois chefs
d'établissement où qu'ell se trouent
c'est le nombre incroyable de tâches
qu'elles ont à accomplir peut-être trop
de tâches est-ce qu'on leur r demande
trop est-ce qu'on vous en demande
beaucoup trop Véronique Roset je ne
dirais pas que nous en on nous en
demande pas trop simplement ça dépend
peut peut-être de l'établissement dans
lequel vous êtes parce que les
établissements sont multiples des grands
et des petits et en fonction de la
taille de l'établissement l'équipe de
direction est plus ou moins renforcée et
il est évident que lorsque vous êtes
dans un petit établissement la multitude
des tâches est plus importante parce que
toutes ces tâches reviennent à une vers
une seule personne qui doit constamment
décider et puis impulser donc je ne
dirais pas trop simplement c'est un
métier passionnant qui est parfois qui
peut parfois être un peu épuisant vous
êtes reconnu un peu dans les profil dans
les personnages qu'on voit dans ce
documentaire oh totalement ou totalement
bien évidemment davantage dans le rôle
de la proviseur puisque finalement
l'établissement que je dirige ressemble
pas mal à celui que qu'on a vu dans le
documentaire bien évidemment et mais
comme dans une carrière vous passez par
différents établissements forcément je
me suis reconnu peut-être un petit peu
moins dans la directrice d'école
maternelle mais il y a des phrases
fortes qui sont prononcées dans ce
documentaire la scolarité ne s'arrête
pas aux portes de l'établissement nous
dit l'une des directrices on est
responsable de tout ce qui se passe dans
l'établissement nous dit une autre c'est
une mission qui mélange tout éducation
sécurité pédagogie des travaux aussi
Stéphan Piednoir est-ce que c'est pas un
peu trop puis un peu trop divers en tout
cas je pense que moi ce qui m'a frappé
c'est dans les profils qui ont été
présentés dans le documentaire c'est
c'est aussi des métiers passion on voit
bien que elles sont ces trois chefs
d'établissement directrices d'école sont
totalement impliqué elles le vivent du
matin au soir et même au-delà et
d'ailleurs on a la directrice d'école
qui dit à un moment donné j'ai fait un
burnout et oui c'était trop parce que
parce queil y a pas de limite en fait
c'est des c'est des fonctions tellement
chronophage avec tellement d'implication
que ça ne s'arrête jamais et euh je fais
un parallèle par rapport avec ce que ce
que vous avez dit Madame proviseur c'est
que euh je compare ça au au aux missions
d'un d'un maire dans une petite commune
au maire dans une grande commune qui est
structuré qui a un service chargé de la
comptabilité charger des affaires
sociales des affaires scolaires et
cetera tout est tout est bien
compartimenté et le maire qui est qui
est aussi un métier une mission passion
peut s'appuyer peut se reposer sur
toutes ces ces fonctionsl ah merde une
petite commune fait tout et c'est pareil
pour un petit établissement scolaire euh
que ce soit dans une école ou collège
lycée on est tout de suite euh on est
multitâche on est on est multifonction
et on doit être au top sur toutes les
fonctions que l'État et que le
législateur en particulier demande mais
ça va jusqu'à des demandes de réparation
on en voie une à un moment donné qui
attend des heures et ça fait des mois
qu'elle attend les réparations un lavabo
boucher enfin je dire est-ce que ça va
pas un peu trop loin est-ce qu'on a bien
défini les contours de cette fonction
pierre mathio ben oui mais justement les
lavabo c'est aussi qu'avec la
décentralisation quand on est chef
d'établissement on relève finalement de
plusieurs autorités bien sûr l'État mais
aussi euh la commune ou le département
ou la région selon le le le niveau
scolaire donc on a en fait on a pas mal
d'interlocuteurs de l'autre côté alors
je parle même pas bien sûr des parents
des profs une accumulation d'acteurs en
face de soi et puis il y a une
accumulation de comment dire de
situation imprévisible il y a un
économiste qui parlait de la tyrannie
des petites décisions je pense que quand
on arrive le lundi matin en gros on sait
ce qu'on va avoir à faire dans la
semaine mais surtout on sait pas ce
qu'on va avoir à faire pendant la
semaine et donc il y a toujours le
risque enfin le risque c'est que quand
on est chef de de de de jongler avec
plein de de de de sujets à gérer au
quotidien qui nous tombent dessus au
risque peut-être parfois de de de perdre
de vue des enjeux plus stratégiques
parce qu'on est un peu son temps est
mangé surtout dans les petits
établissements on n'est pas très encadré
le temps est mangé par la gestion des
une bonne journée c'est une journée à
l'issus de laquelle on n'est pas sorti
de la route il on passer l'expression et
on a réussi à gérer à peu près tout mais
avec des des dossiers d'une d'une
comment dire d'une diversité
extraordinaire ce qui fait le sel je
pense du métier et parfois aussi sa
frustration passionnant mais épuisant
aussi Éric choni vous avez un regard
plus international que nous tous sur
cette fonction est-ce que c'est propre à
la France c'est ce côté multitach et
multicasquette du chef d'établissement
et ce risque d'épuisement dont l'une des
des femmes de ce documentaire parle
d'ailleurs oui mais c'est c'est une
réalité notamment pour les directeurs
d'école en maternelle en élémentaire qui
n'ont pas vraiment un statut directeur
d'école mais qui ont un nombre de tâches
administrative très importante donc ça
crée de l'épuisement mais c'est ce qu'on
retrouve aussi dans les autres p pays
aujourd'hui on a à la fois des pénuries
d'enseignants mais on a aussi du mal à
trouver des chefs d'établissement dans
beaucoup de pays et c'est pas
nécessairement une question de salaire
c'est aussi une question de tâches
administrativ qui sont de plus en plus
nombreuses et puis aussi une pression
des parents les parents sont stressés
pour l'orientation de leurs enfants les
parents ont envie que ça se passe bien à
l'intérieur des écoles donc le chef
d'établissement aujourd'hui encore plus
qu'avant doit gérer les parents et les
rassurer et ça rajoute à l'épuisement
c'est clair et j'insiste un petit peu
vous venez de dire que c'était pas
propre à la France c'est un phénomène
qui est relativement général oui c'est
c'est le le phénomène international
aujourd'hui on narrive plus à trouver
des enseignants des personnels de
direction il y a moindre intérêt pour ce
métier aussi parce que il y a pas
toujours les évolutions de carrière poss
possiblebl les évolutions de salaire
donc aujourd'hui les évolutions en terme
de formation aussi une fois qu'on est en
exercice on le voit bien dans ce
reportage les chefs d'établissements ont
besoin de formation continue mais ils
ont pas du tout le temps d'en suivre
donc tous ces élément
hudie deer
mé que ça soit enseignant ou plus tard
chef d'établissement il y a quelque
chose de relativement nouveau aussi qui
est intervenu et qui semble s'accélérer
j'en parl en introduction c'est les
questions de sécurité le risque
terroriste et même le risque de tension
à l'intérieur de l'établissement entre
communauté ou sur des questions
d'identité Véronique rosé c'est un
problème nouveau que gère aussi le chef
d'établissement ça nous avons toujours
gérer la sécurité des établissements ce
n'est pas nouveau il faut faire
attention parce que bien évidemment que
le drame de ces dernières semaines nous
fait douter de de ce de ce qu'il faut
faire dans les établissements faut-il
les fermer totalement les bonciriser et
Lesch d'établissements ne sont pas
d'accord avec ça parce que ça reste un
établissement d'enseignement et donc il
est normal que l'on entre et que l'on
sorte et ce n'est pas une prison et donc
bien évidemment nous travaillons
avec les collectivités TER pour voir ce
que nous pouvons faire pour sécuriser au
maximum ce lieu qui doit être un lieu
protégé et protecteur pour les élèves
mais avec une peur plus grande quand
même chez les chefs d'établissement un
sens des responsabilités plus grand
parce que là on parle de la vie et de la
mort des élèves mais aussi des
enseignant est-ce que cette pression
s'est accentuée ces dernières
années forcément un peu forcément bien
sûr
euh pourquoi parce que finalement dès
qu'un drame comme celui qui vient
d'arriver se se se passe
il y a une telle médiatisation autour de
cet événement que finalement les
professeurs ont peur et que leschelles
d'établissement sont dans l'obligation
de finalement de rassurer et de euê
laissent leurs enfants dans cet
établissement toute la journé et les
parents pour rassurer et justement ou
sur les sur les niveaux de de décision
de prise de décision les chefs
d'établissement ont besoin d'être
appuyés depuis depuis Samuel paatti
évidemment il y a des des procédures qui
sont mises en place ce qu'on observe
c'est que il y a un temps de réaction
qui est trop long pour que pour qu'on
assure la sécurité je dis pas qu'on
puisse assurer à 100 % que des drames
tels que que que ce auquel on a assisté
ne se reproduisent mais néanmoins on on
l'a bien vu sur l'affaire Samuel Patti
il y avait des signaux depuis plusieurs
semaines je pense qu'à un moment donné
ça a manqué de fluidité pour qu'on dise
bon automatiquement retrait du
professeur des des mesure extrêmement
extrêmement radical extrêmement rapide
pour mettre à l'abri pour mettre en
sécurité au moins l'enseignant puisque
là les ça c'était concentré sur un
enseignant c'était aussi vrai sur ça a
été vrai sur sur Dominique Bernard ce
que je veux dire c'est que quand même
l'école est le reflet de la société et
ce qui existait avec des bagarres vous
parliez de bande oui on a pu observer
des bagarres c'est quand même pas du
même c'est quand même pas du même ordre
et aujourd'hui la responsabilité le
stress des enseignants et donc des chefs
d'établissement il est monté à un niveau
extrêmement élevé euh on le voit dans
les sondages d'opinion un enseignant sur
deux aujourd'hui se se censure
s'autocensure pour éviter d'avoir des
soucis donc il y a un phénomène qui qui
est nouveau quand même et qui qui qui
est sans commune mesure avec ce qu'on a
pu connaître dans les décennies précéd
et je rappelle quef je crois qu'ils
n'ont pas de formation éc Chabon sont
pas formé c'est c'est c'est un véritable
problème c'est ce qu'on disait sur les
enseignants c'est ce qu'on dit aussi sur
les chefs d'établissement euh la
formation est pas suffisamment
développée une fois qu'ils sont en
exercice ils ont plus de temps leur
emploi du temps et on l'a entendu au
moins trois quatre fois dans le
reportage est complètement pris donc ils
ont plus le temps pour être proche de
leurs équipes pédagogiques on le voit la
la la la principale de de de lycée qui
est très contente de suivre un un cours
de de parole de prise de parole en
public et qui prend un véritable plaisir
et qui dit qu'elle a jamais le temps de
le faire dans son emploi du temps donc
il faudrait vraiment dégager du temps
pour les chefs d'établissement c'est ça
aussi peut-être leur permettre d'être
plus épanouis dans le métier même s'ils
sont passionnés on a des exemples types
là euh de modèle quelque part mais on
sait que il y a beaucoup de chefs
d'établissement euh qui ont beaucoup
plus de difficultés h on les entend
aussi se plaindre des injonctions
nombreuses et contradictoires venant de
là-haut du ministère de l'Éducation
nationale pierre mathieou est-ce que ça
c'est pas quelque chose qui peut être
quand même amélioré ben écoutez moi
l'expérience que j'ai c'est qu' a une
espèce de pas deux permanents les
personn de direction mais aussi les
profs sont en même temps en attente
d'une forme de liberté qu'on leur fasse
confiance et en même temps ils aiment
bien quand même aussi avoir des
consignes mais c'est normal hein pour se
se sécuriser donc on est vraiment moi
l'expérience que j'en ai très modeste
c'est de se dire dans les même parfois
les mêmes réunions les mêmes personnes
vont nous dire faites-nous confiance
donc en gros donnez-nous les clés du
camion mais où est le où est le texte où
est l'arrêté où la circulaire qui va un
petit peu encadrer ce qu'on fait il y a
12000 collèges et lycées je crois en
France donc à chaque fois c'est des
situations différentes et je pense qu'il
y a des attentes différentes en réalité
les gens sont plus ou moins à l'aise
selon leur passé selon le niveau de
formation initiale etue qu'ils ont eu
ils sont plus ou moins à l'aise avec
cette idée de l'autonomie de la liberté
mais factuellement il y a trop de
consignes ou pas Véronique rosé soyons
franc trop il y en a trop et dans dans
des chances trop rapprochées en fait ce
que ce que nous regrettons finalement
c'est vous avez des exemples concrets
qui vous viennent c'està dire je sais
pas sur l'équivalent de 3 semaines un
mois des injonctions qui vous viennent
de toutes parts de là-haut vous souriez
mais dit dites-le ditesle la dernière
sur le harcèlement donc voilà il nous a
demandé donc à la veille des vacances de
mettre en œuvre pour donc le 9 novembre
une journée du harcèlement avec une un
temps banalisé sur le
harcèlement heureusement monsieur le
ministre a écouté les organisations
syndicales et à donner un peu de
souplesse à tout ça mais il n'est pas
possible le temps de l'école n'est pas
celui de du temps politique et donc il
faut il faut à un moment donné
l'entendre et le comprendre le temps de
l'école nous avons besoin d'un petit peu
de temps pour mettre en place ce à quoi
nous croyons parce que nous y croyons à
toutes ces choses mais il faut juste
nous laisser un peu plus de temps pour
les mettre en en œuvre et là notre
autonomie est importante parce que
chacun dans son établissement va le
mettre en en œuvre avec les spécificités
de son établissement c'est un appel
incroyable que vous lancez il est fort
cet appel on le sent quand même Stéphane
piennois laissezleur le temps le temps
politique n'est pas celui de l'éducation
mais je valide parce que bon comme comme
vous l'avez dit je je suis moiême
enseignant c'est c'est de formation et
c'est mon métier et et on a assisté le
temps politique enfin c'est le c'est le
3è il y a eu un un ministre de
l'éducation qui a fait tout un cacana
mais c'est le deuxè en en peu de temps
là et on voit bien que les les les
établissements scolaires ont besoin de
temps pour mettre en œuvre par exemple
un un projet d'établissement c'est
quelque chose qui se qui se travaille
qui se peaufine au d'une année sur
l'autre euh on peut pas changer comme ça
au milieu d'année parce que il y a un
nouveau ministre qui qui qui prend telle
ou telle décision ou un fait divers
tragique ou oui une pression médiatique
sur l'autonomie je ser j'aurai quand
même un mot un petit peu différent à
bémol sur je pense qu'il faut mettre à
part le prier degré du second degré euh
parce que il y a pas de personnalité
juridique pour le 1er degré euh des
directeurs des directeurs directrices
d'école on le disait tout à l'heure pour
les lavabau mais ça veut dire qu'elles
n'ont pas la la possibilité eux-mêmes
ils n'ont pas la possibilité de
commander des travaux il faut passer par
la tutelle c'est-à-dire en l'occurrence
la commune la mairie il faut un chef
d'établissement à à notre sens c'est en
tout cas une position qu' qu'on défend
parce que si pour des problèmes de
sécurité il faut décider tout simplement
un exemple basique il faut décider de
fermer les grilles de l'établissement il
faut qu'il y ait quelqu'un qui ait
l'autorité sur ses collègues pour dire
je ferme l'établissement et pas en
concertant un conseil d'école ça peut
pas se passer comme ça il faut aller
très vite parce que parfois le danger
est imminent et donc il faut quelqu'un
qui prenne des décisions c'est ça un
chef et on y reviendra sur la question
de la hiérarchie de l'autorité Eric
charbonnier peut-être d'abord sur ces
injonctions multiples venant de oui
c'est c'est vraiment une une spécificité
un peu française on a des ministres de
l'éducation qui sont passionné
d'éducation et on a des débats qui n'ont
pas lieu ailleurs c'est-à-dire que un
ministre va donner son avis sur les
programmes d'histoire un autre sur le
nombre de jours d'école finalement c'est
pas son rôle forcément et et ça crée des
incohérences et du découragement au
niveau des écoles je vous donne
l'exemple de la réforme des rythmes
scolaires on est le seul pays au monde
qui depuis 2008 a changé quatre fois de
rythme scolaire on a eu quatre journées
d'école quatre matinées d'école puis on
est passé à 5 matinées d'école puis on
est revenu à 4 puis aujourd'hui on peut
choisir et et finalement il y a il y a
une perte de cohérence et puis ce débat
il est très quantitatif en France on n'
pas un débat suffisamment axé sur la
qualité d'éducation par exemple si on
revient sur ces rythmes scolaires le
vrai déb c'est qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire de mieux avec les élèves si on a
CIN matinées d'école c'est pas dire on
va avoir cinq matinées d'école ou on va
faire plus de math plus de Français ça
va régler les problèmes des des élèves
donc il faudrait vraiment qu'on change
de débat et d'avoir un ministre de
l'éducation qui donne les grandes lignes
et puis après de faire confiance aux
acteurs pour mettre en place et
s'approprier les réformes et pas revenir
en arrière comme on le fait deation
c'est une passion la enfin c'est une
passion politique l'éducation depuis la
3e république comme l'école a été l'un
des ferments de la de disons de du
retour de la République et de de son
imposition comme comme modèle politique
dominant le la enfin tous les ministres
de l'éducation se ENF ils sont des
approches politiques pas au sens parce
que le mot politique est très noble mais
pas voilà mais pas comme vient de le
dire pas au sens de donner des grandes
orientations puis de donner du temps au
temps mais très vite là les les enquêtes
enfin les les résultats de PISA vont pas
tarder à tomber
euh 5 décemb vous faites les gros yeux
comme s'ils étaient catastrophiques vous
le savez déjà non j'ai pas vu
encore inér sa par expérience c'est que
ça c'est très attendu par le le le le
enfin le ministre actuel et ce qui est
intéressant c'est que le ministre actuel
va devoir rendre des compte sur des
données PISA qui vont porter sur une
époque où c'était même pas le ministre
d'avant c'était le ministre d'avant tu
lui voilà donc c'est quand même et ça en
France par rapport à beaucoup d'autres
pays où quand même le le jeu politique
et l'éducation est laissé quand même sur
le côté du jeu politique au sens du jeu
politicien en France ça fait l'objet
c'est les passion parlementaires enfin
la question éducative en revanche la la
fonction du ministre c'est aussi de
donner des consignes claires un cadre
clair et je pense à la BAA évidemment le
message de gabrielal en début de ses
pris de fonction tranche avec le
ministre précédent qui était au mieux
sans avis au pire avec des avec un avis
quand même qui était très très
contestable là au moins il y a y a un
message si ce n'est présidentiel au
moins gouvernemental qui est extrêmement
important pour les chefiss ét très très
apprécié par les chefs d'établissement
même si tout n'est pas réglé mais ça a
été très apprécié par les chefs
d'établissement c'était nous attendions
cela un mot avant de justement parler de
cette question de la hiérarchie du chef
d'établissement versus les enseignants
Véronique rosé vous aurez remarqué que
le titre du documentaire a choisi le
féminin c'est proviseur eu et les
protagonistes du film sont trois femmes
les derniers chiffres officiels montrent
qu'on est à parité quasi parfaite dans
les personnels de direction 13406
personnels de direction 6510 hommes 6896
femmes le métier devient même légèrement
plus féminin quel enseignement en tiré
quelle conséquence le nombre de femmes
devenu personnel de direction a a
augmenté a fortement augmenté ces
dernières années mais euh ce chiffre
peut être trompeur parce que si nous
sommes 53 % de femmes contre 47 %
d'hommes dans cette fonction les postes
occupés ne sont ne reflètent pas
finalement cette presque parité puisque
les postes occupés restent quand même
pour les les établissements de grande
taille ou
prestigieux quand même plus attribué aux
hommes qu'aux femmes même si je dois
reconnaître néanmoins que le ministère a
fait de grosord eff for depuis 2016 dans
l'expression chef d'établissement il y a
le mot chef et je demandais en
introduction s'il n'y avait pas un abus
de langage parce qu'en effet un
directeur ou une directrice d'école n'a
pas vraiment voir pas du tout autorité
sur les enseignants
écoutez il y a pas de rapport de
hiérarchie dans le premier degré
c'est-à-dire que moi je suis pas le
supérieur hiérarchique de mes collègues
en fait je suis un collègue de travail
qui a une fonction directeur mais je
suis pas du tout leur supérieur
hiérarchique voilà après il y a des
choses sur lesquelles voilà
l'organisation fait que il y a des
choses des fois qui sont un peu plus
descendantes parce que il faut que les
choses avancent et se mettent en place
mais sinon on est plutôt sur un rapport
d'égalité on fonctionne beaucoup de
manière collégiale donc on se réunit
beaucoup ça reste une interrogation
peut-être même une énigme Stéphane
Piednoir pourquoi pas de de rapport
hiérarchique entre le chef
d'établissement j'invente pas le terme
chef d'établissement et les enseignants
d'après vous parce que parce que d'abord
une école n'est pas un établissement
scolaire euh c'est pas que de la
sémantique les les les connaisseurs
savent mais mais il y a pas de
personnalité juridique encore une fois
pour une école hein premier degré donc
maternel élémentaire tout l'enseignement
primaire et vraiment il y a un distingo
à faire avec le secondaire et les les la
position c'est effectivement un collègue
qui a en suce de son service la plupart
du temps des responsabilités de
direction d'école avec la plupart du
temps en tout cas très souvent pas de
décharge c'est un collègue qui assume
des fonctions supplémentaires il y a
vraiment quelque chose pour nous hein
qui qui manque on a essayé de proposer
avec nos nos collègues de la commission
culture Max Brisson avait déposé des
propositions dans dans ce sens-là pour
dire allons jusqu'au bout et faisons du
chef de l'école on l'appelle comme on
veut mais en tout cas un vrai chef
d'établissement avec une une
responsabilité hiérarchique on sait que
les les enseignants ils sont très
majoritairement opposés ça reste très
atypique dans les pays de l'OCDE on a
des chefs d'établissements dans les
écoles maternelles élémentaires dans la
plupart des pays c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont
des salaires assez proches
de ceux qui vont exercer au collège et
lycée donc ça doit être une véritable
réflexion aujourd'hui en France alors on
a aussi une spécificité d'avoir beaucoup
d'établissements on a plus de 50000
écoles maternelles et écoles
élémentaires c'est beaucoup plus que
dans les autres pays donc on aurait du
mal d'avoir un chef d'établissement pour
pour chaque école du on peut imaginer il
y a des choses qui se font encore une
fois dans le privé avec des
regroupements des associations de
d'école du premier degré et on nomme un
chef d'établissement pour deux trois
écoles de manière à avoir un un effectif
mais çaut que très concrètement les
enseignants n'ont pas de compte à rendre
à leur à leur chef d'établ en fait si je
peux me permettre il y a deux modèles il
y a le modèle qui de l'école élémentaire
et de de l'enseignement supérieur ù
quand on dirige on est primich interpess
on est l'un parmi les autres c'est qu'on
reste un enseignant qui exerce une
responsabilité parfois à temps plein
parfois pas à temps plein et ça a des
avantages quand même c'est qu'on reste
considéré par les collègues comme étant
un collègue alors que quand on devient
personnel de direction on change de
corps tu voyez ce que je veux dire mais
Véronique rosé c'est c'est c'est un
sujet ou pas qui il y a pas de de
d'autorité de la part du chef
d'établissement sur les enseignants
est-ce que c'est un problème est-ce que
ça devrait changer non je ne dirais pas
que c'est un problème non et ça ne doit
pas changer en fait il y a cette
autorité fonctionnelle nous sommes nous
avons un rôle pédagogique effectivement
nous menons des des des projets nous
sommes là pour piloter en fait les
moyens et cetera et cetera donc nous
avons un je crois que l'autorité n'est
pas remise en question par les
enseignants le pouir de sanction un
professeur je vous donne un exemple qui
est tout le temps absent ou ou dont les
élèves se plaignent parce que le cours
est mal fait c'estàd que personne au
sein de l'établissement ne peut y
remédier en fait c'est ce que vous nous
dites alors c'est c'est difficile parce
que un un un enseignant effectivement
qui euh qui ne fait pas tout n'assume
pas complètement ses missions tel comme
il le devrait il est c'est compliqué de
le de pour que ça arrive à l'inspecteur
d'académie parfois il y a a quand même
des filtres si vous me permettez
l'expression qui sont assez fort et qui
empêche justement la la prise de
conscience la prise de mais ditesous
franchement vous vous sentez impuissante
quand quand il y a un professeur qui
pose un souci on ne peut rien vous ne
pouvez rien faire c'est long en fait je
ne me sens pas impuissante simplement
c'est long lorsque quelque chose est mis
en œuvre c'est long et nous avons nous
nous appuyons aussi il ne faut pas
oublier les inspecteurs dans dans cette
chaîne mais que certains professurs
voient une fois tous les 10 ans oui
enfin ça dépend ça dépend là aussi je
crois qu'il ne faut pas être dans la
caricature les les inspecteurs sont
davantage présents dans les dans les
établissements supérieur hiérarchique
des enseignants ce sont les les
inspecteurs oui oui fait oui oui de fait
oui oui oui mais les chefs
d'établissement travaillent quand même
de plus en plus avec les les inspecteurs
et lorsqu'il y a un souci avec un
enseignant finalement le chef
d'établissement s'appuie sur
l'inspecteur pour faire monter faire un
rapport faire remonter les
dysfonctionnements et c'est là après que
je dis que il ne faut pas être pressé
voilà il ne se passe pas rien mais il ne
faut pas être pr quand des parents se
plaignent juste raison ou pas d' ignant
l'argument consistant à dire il faut pas
être pressé les parents si un enseignant
absent de manière récurrente d'expliquer
que faut pas être pressé quand il y a le
bac qui s'annonce par exemple et que le
prof n'est pas là il y a une espèce de
yat quand je pointe le sujet de façon
naïve et sans jugement mais réellement
donc le chef d'établissement n'a pas
autorité s'il se passe le moindre
problème avec un enseignant en France
c'est vrai que il y a cette liberté
pédagogique avec les enseignants qui
font cours et qui n'ont pas à rendre
forcément des comptes à leur chefs
d'établissement on le voit dans nos stat
statistique nous la France et le pays où
les chefs d'établissement vont moins
observer ce qui se passe dans la classe
de leurs collègues ou les enseignants
travaillent le moins en équipe où ils
sont évalués si peu voilà on a une
culture de liberté pédagogique qui veut
dire qu'aujourd'hui les enseignants ont
un peu cette cette liberté c'est
culturel c'est philosophique c'est
quelque chose qu'on qu'on ne s'utorise
pas je pe me permettre je crois que le
les les chefs ont essayent d'incarner
une culture collective et la
les ignants ont une cure profnelle quand
Mme une culture individualiste et
persones j'appelle les perdir les
personnes de direction ont du mal à
construire une un rapport collégial au
travail dans l'établissement je dis avec
mes mots à moi mais quand même on
constate la réforme du bac que j'essayé
de mettre en place qui a été très
critiqué par sur la les plans
d'évaluation d'établissements donc en
gros pour l'accompagnement du contrôle
continu les chefs ont beaucoup de mal à
réunir les enseignants pour se mettre
d'accord sur les processus de de
contrôle continu alors que pour nous ici
ça nous paraît assez évident c'est assez
compliqué à mettre en place alors si
vous allez en Finlande au Canada
Royaume-Uni vous avez les chefs
d'établissements qui vont même recruter
les enseignants qui vont décider avec
eux du programme de formation continue
ou pour aller jusqu ce pouvoir jusqu'au
pouvoir de muter au pouvoir de sur le ça
va jusqu'au pouvoir de muter dans dans
certains pays voilà mais c'est pas
forcément avoir plus d'autorité pour
sanctionner les enseignants c'est être
là aussi pour les accompagner pour avoir
une culture de l'établissement qui va ê
re au service de développement de projet
d'une formation continue sur les besoin
chrait énormément de choses sur même le
comportement des enseignants
potentiellement c'est que avec aussi des
risques des travers c'estd de vouloir
plaire au chefs d'établissement pour
être récompensé en échange c'estd ce qui
peut aussi se passer dans le privé quand
on a un chef la question se pose pas
dans le secondaire la question se pose
pas dans le secondaire on a un chef
d'établissement un principal un
préviseur qui est notre supérieur
hiérarchique qui nous qui a autorité sur
les
ben on est noté il y a une notation
pédagogique notation par l'inspecteur
mais il y une notion notation
administrative alors c'est vrai que on
est très vite au au plafond mais enfin
quand même on moi j'ai vu des collègues
dont la notation administrative a
diminué pour des raisons d'absentéisme
oui c'était des cas plutôt lourds mais
enfin ça c'est ça existe euh bon sur
l'autonomie quand même je vourrais dire
un mot parce que il y a quelque ch une
expérimentation
juste parce que là il faut quand même
que je rebondisse effectivement lorsque
le chef d'établissement est là pour
alerter lorsqu'il y a un
dysfonctionnement il je répète il il
alerte avec donc le l'inspecteur
l'inspecteur et en fait ces rapports
finalement sont destinés au rectorat au
service de de la de des rectorats du
rectorat qui c'est le recteur au final
Infiné qui prendra la décision de
sanctionner de de de mettre en place une
commission disciplinaire et cetera donc
il ne se passe pas rien en fait je
voudrais vraiment on pas le sentiment
que finalement le chef d'établissement
ne peut rien faire ce n'est pas du tout
la réalité alors oui vous je vous laisse
terminer allez-y autom parce que il y a
cette expérimentation à Marseille vous
sa le président de la République a est
aller à Marseille qui a constaté un
certain nombre de choses dit il faut il
faut innover il faut permettre
d'ailleurs on le voit sur l'école hein
puisque c'est c'est dans le quartier de
Marseille extrêmement pauvre quand même
et donc permettre des choses des
innovations avec des crédits
supplémentaire elle le dit c'est c'est
c'est formidable on arrive à faire des
des choses qu'on qu'onimaginait pas avec
du matériel simplement du mobilier faire
venir les parents en dehors du temps
scolaire moi je trouve que c'est plutôt
là leur place que sur le temps scolaire
un avis personnel euh c'est exactement
ce qu'on a proposé au sein de là encore
une fois au sein de la commission
Culture pour mon groupe euh c'est
exactement ce ce qui permettrait dans
certains certains coins de France de
faire évoluer de stabiliser les équipes
éducatives aussi parce que on voit bien
dans les dans les établissements
difficiles la réputation euh et bien ça
tourne beaucoup on envoie de jeunes
collègues de jeunes professeurs sans
expérience qui sont vite démunis qui n
REST et qui n'ontune envie c'est de
c'est c'est de partir donc ça ça
permettrait de stabiliser un peu les
équipes avec peut-être éventuellement
aussi une petite latitude sur le niveau
de rémunération je rappelle que
directeur d'école quand on débute c'est
1700 € net ça fait pas totalement rêvé
non plus quoi bien sûr alors on l'a pas
encore évoqué mais il y a aussi la
solitude hein qui va de paire avec la
fonction de chef d'établissement et
cette solitude elle est encore plus
forte lorsqu'on est face à des collègues
peu accommodant et cela arrive
apparemment on va revoir ensemble cette
séquence qui vous a marqué je le sais où
la proviseur se bat pour que certains
acceptent de venir un peu plus tôt 2
jours dans l'année le jour des
inscriptions h et maintenant parle de
sujet qui fâche les
horaires l'année dernière quand on a
ouvert les grilles c'était de la folie
il y avait une file d'attente dehors
c'était de la folie il faut qu'on ouvre
plus tôt pour que ça démarre plus
calmement donc oui je sais ça fait un
jour tôt à se lever mais on peut le
faire une fois dans
l'année je vous écoute la dernière on
avait fait 9h 16h je ma
tête on va pass à
18h c'est pas un jour c'est 3 jours du
coup c'est les 3 jours de secondes non
le vendredi on peut alléger en fait
puisque là on aura que les gens sur
rendez-vous quasiment mais voilà obliger
des parents à prendre des demi-journées
de congé c'est facile pour nous par
exemple je suis pas sûre qu'à Monoprix
ce soit très simple de dire qu'on prend
qu'on arrivera en retard pour aller
inscrire son
enfant Véronique Ros qu'est-ce qu'elle
dit cette séquence elle dit tout
simplement que le chef d'établissement
peut pas faire preuve d'autorité
d'autoritarisme mais qu'il est obligé de
convaincre et finalement de rappeler à
chacun que nous avons une serv une
mission de service public et que nous
sommes là quand même et pour les élèves
et pour les familles et que dans ce
cas-là tout simplement il il faut faire
il faut accepter de de faire un petit
peu au-delà des horaires qui sont prévus
de façon à ce que elle est caricaturale
cette scène ou elle est elle est oui
c'estàdire que c'est c'est pas fréquent
en fait ce genre de problème si ça alors
elle est pas caricaturale
ça arrive mais en règle générale chacun
comprend à un moment donné qu'il doit
faire un effort parce que nous sommes là
au service des familles et des élèves et
que pour le bien de l'établissement
chacun doit faire un effort donc ça me
fait sourire même rire parce que
finalement ça m'est arrivé assez assez
régulièrement mais je n'ai jamais on m'a
jamais opposer un refus je n'ai jamais
dans ma carrière eu un
refus c'est du bon sens pierre ma à un
moment donné on se rappelle plus mais il
propose que ce soit les AED qui s'en
occupent c'est en gros les contractuels
il y a des routines enfin c'est quand
même un niveau d'épuisement pour arriver
à convaincre si on a on a d si une
proviseur doit faire ce travail à une
réunion avec toutes les personnes
concernées pour 2 jours dans l'année
qu'ils arrivent une demi-heure plutôt
c'està dire que quand on veut faire des
réformes plus importantes alors là il
faut se faut se lever la veille qu du
problème il est aussi là c'està dire que
il y a je sais pas une corporations des
corporations qui sont quand même un
petit peu difficiles à convaincre que
c'est compliqué que c'est une machine
lourde un certains ministres a un jour
parlé de mammouth est-ce que c'est ça
c'est une machine lourde et quand on a
on est chef d'établissement avec 50 100
profs ça ce qui peut arriver il y a un
vrai rôle de de conviction c'est un vrai
rôle de manager en fait hein on a une
équipe parfois conséquente à à manager
c'est c'est du vrai management d'équipe
et il faut faire confiance pour que dans
le privé pardonnez-moi les les employés
a priori ne rechignent pas arriver
plutôt ils ont pas tellement le choix
ils savent aussi que non là c'est
peut-être un peu caricatural du coup il
y a des difficultés probablement vous
savez quand il s'agit de de grignoter
une demi-heure par-ci par là ce qui est
important c'est qu'il y a une adhésion
bon on voit que ça ça grogne un peu mais
que on va on va y arriver mais c'est de
jours dans l'année c'est une on parle
d'une demi-heure venir une demi-heure
plutôt le matin bon je pense mais il
faut il faut pour ça une une complicité
que le le corps professoral sache qu'
comprennent bien que le chef
d'établissement est avec eux et que
c'est pour le bien de l'établissement
c'est pour le bien de tous qui leur
demande un petit effort ponctuellement
sur de jours quo mais c'est vrai c'est
quand même assez incroyable de voir
comment elle est stressée face à cette
situation alors qu'elle gère dans tout
le reportage des situations qui sont
bien plus difficiles mais parler à son
équipe pour justement avoir l'adhésion
sur venir Plô je voudrais quand même
dire parce que là je me je sens quand
même une petite caricature parce que les
professeurs quand même n nous faisons
énormément de réunions des réunions très
peu dans la journée mais surtout le soir
et les professeurs sont extrêmement
sollicités pour des réunions
pédagogique touchant à l'orientation les
réunions parents professeurs les
conseils de classe il y a même
énormément de réunions qui se font et
les les professeurs sont là ils ne sont
pas à pointer finalement les
heures voit chez les enseignants qu' a
un nombre d'heures invisibles qui ne
cesse de de grossiroui que je trouve
Marcant dans cette séquence c'est que ça
participe de l'isolement du chef
d'établissement c'est que c'est lui tout
seul qui doit quand même convaincre
alors que lui non plus il a pas
forcément envie de venir une demi-heure
plutôt trop mais c'est quand on parle de
management c'est exactement ça nous
avons vraiment un rôle de management de
plus en plus important nous avons je je
trouve que par
rapport au moment où je suis entrée dans
la fonction je passe beaucoup plus de
temps dans la journée à être près des
des personnels à les écouter à à à les
emmener finalement dans la même
direction et et c'est vrai que tout le
reste du travail finalement se fait
lorsque lorsque tout le monde est parti
et c'est finalement la charge la
surcharge de travail elle vient de là
également parce que nous avons un rôle
pédagogique donc avec les équipes
d'enseignants et les autres personnels
mais nous avons aussi la responsabilité
de tout ce qui est
administratif
financier sécurité et et c'est là
finalement que le le le les fonctions de
chef d'établissement sont lourdes alors
ça m'amène à ma dernière question et ce
sera un dernier tour de table
relativement rapide si possible quelle
serait la mesure à prendre pour
améliorer le quotidien des chefs
d'établissements si on devait conclure
cette émission c'est un peu brutal comme
question mais dans l'idée qu'est-ce
qu'on devrait faire j'ai parlé de
l'autonomie tout à l'heure je pense
qu'il a y a vraiment une confiance à
accorder alléger les charges
administratives on voit bien que voil il
y a des marges de manœuvre en fait on a
pas parlé mais pour le premier degré il
y a 108 heur en plus de l'enseignement
dans les dans leseple les collèges et
les lycées il y a aussi des marches de
manœuvre sauf qu'aujourd'hui enfin de
plus en plus et de manière récurrente
quand les ministres prennent des
décisions ils disent vous allez mettre
en place la mesure que j'ai envie de
porter mais vous allez le prendre sur
vos marges de manœuvre ça c'est pas
possible une réforme elle doit
s'accompagner deux moyens à chaque fois
soit on a les moyens de de ses ambitions
soit on ne fait pas et puis revaloriser
évidemment la fonction une question
d'autorité aussi revaloris parce que ça
fait beaucoup làou ça fait beaucoup mes
je pense que c'est essentiel quand on on
sait qu'il y a 20 % des des des places
de concours qui sont pas pourvu il y a
aussi un manque d'attractivité du métier
n'oublions pas que les chefs
d'établissements c'est des c'est des
anciens professeurs la plupart du temps
et que si on peinene à recruter des
anciens de des professeurs on retrouvera
on décalera le problème sur les chefs
d'établissement les chefs
d'établissement effectivement il y a
l'entrée dans la fonction en fait elle
n'est absolument pas attractive puisque
les les enseignants lorsqu'ils font
quelques heures supplémentaires
finalement gagnent davantage qu'un chef
d'établissement lorsqu'il lorsqu'il
commence ensuite le le parcours de
carrière fait que finalement il y a
quand même une progression il ne faut
pas dire non plus que qu'il n'y a pas de
progression néanmoins l'entrée dans la
fonction n'est pas du tout valorisante
et pour moi effectivement je vous
rejoins totalement c'est le pôle
administratif qu'il faut renforcer un
vrai pôle administratif permettrait au
chef d'établissement de d'être de mieux
faire leur métier éc charbon et Pierre
matthou sû il y a différentes mesures
différenci sur le premier degré maternel
élémentaire il faut vraiment donner un
pouvoir hiérarchique au directeur
d'école c'est c'est indispensable pour
les aider aussi pour dans la prise de
décisions qui qu'ils ont à prendre au
quotidien et sur le second degré il faut
leur offrir du temps pour de la
formation je crois qu'on a tous besoin
de se former tout au long de la vie et
c'est dommage de voir que l'ensemble des
tâches administratives bouffle le temps
des chefs d'établissement il faut leur
offrir du temps pour une formation sur
leurs besoins pour pouvoir se sérer
l'esprit de temps à autres pierre Matth
oui ben je résume non mais entrer dans
la carrière déroulement de carrière et
formation parce que c'est
malheureusement la formation c'est le
luxe en gros ils s'inscrivent à une
formation et finalement ils n'y vont pas
parce qu'il y a un dossier qui leur
tombe dessus et comme j'ai la chance
maintenant de participer à la formation
continue des et initial des personnels
de direction je sens quand même
l'importance qu'il y a à entrer armé
dans dans dans dans ce métier armé au
sens deun bonne culture générale une
connaissance juridique et cetera ça ça
manque beaucoup et je pense que quand on
se sent armé on se sent plus plus en
situation de de de maîtriser les les
dossiers qu'on a géré voilà plein de
choses de dites plein d'appels lancés
merci merci à vous quatre d'avoir
participé à cette émission merci à vous
de nous avoir suivi comme chaque semaine
émission et documentaire à retrouver en
replay sur notre plateforme publsena.fr
à très bientôt sur publicsena
[Musique]
merci